hello everyone I'm Peter Bauer welcome
to Pete's lab today we have another one
of our short little lectures vignettes
if you will on subjects related to
brownfields and groundwater
today's topic is porosity porosity is
the percentage of open space in rock or
regolith usually we think of rock as
being completely solid but in many cases
there are fractures or cracks sometimes
open spaces that can provide some
porosity regolith on the other hand is
the loose material at the surface of the
earth mud sand gravel and so forth and
it is composed of particles and those
particles have spaces between them which
can give you a rather large amount of
open space or as we'll see porosity
there are some other subjects that we're
going to touch upon permeability bulk
volume bulk density density of particles
volumes of the particles and so forth
we'll make some measurements and we'll
discuss their significance I have here a
pebble of quartz and if one were to try
to determine the volume of this pebble
most people understand that if we have a
graduated cylinder with in this case 110
milliliters of water that by dropping
the pebble into the water the water
level will rise and we should be able to
determine the volume of the pebble by
difference so let me drop this in here
and we can see that the water level has
gone up and the new water level is 130
milliliters meaning that the difference
130 minus 110 20 milliliters is the
volume of the pebble milliliters we
should also understand is the same
volume as a little cube one centimeter
on a side that is a cubic centimeter or
CC is exactly the same volume as a
milliliter while most understand that
one can determine the volume of a pebble
by volume difference by dropping it into
a graduated cylinder with some liquid in
it it gets a little more confusing when
we have more than one particle but it's
really the same principle if we were to
dump all these particles in this case a
nice pile of half inch plastic beads
into a liquid - surely the volume would
rise and what would we have done we
would have measured the volume of all of
these particles not just one but many
here for instance is a beaker of sin
consisting of hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of particles we could do the
same thing by dropping the sand into a
water watching the water level rise in
determining the volume of all the
particles that's exactly what we're
going to do okay so let's begin the
experiment before you begin the
experiment you should all have a copy of
the handout particles porosity bulk
density and particle density if you
don't have it pause the video and go to
the website print it out and then start
watching the video again so let's begin
the first thing that we'll want to do is
to determine the weight of this beaker
okay the weight of the beaker is 170 1.3
grams so if you would please enter that
data on your sheet in item number two
the weight of the beaker and the next
thing we're going to do is determine the
weight of the beaker plus two particles
again the particles are the plastic that
is starving be 1/2 inch in diameter and
we're going to use a weight to assist us
here we're getting close
and the weight of the beaker plus the
beads is five hundred and thirty nine
point eight grams so please enter that
on your sheet five thirty nine point
eight by subtracting the weight of the
beaker from the weight of the beaker
plus the particles we can find out the
weight of the particles and that turns
out to be three hundred and sixty six
point seven grams so we've determined
one thing and that is the weight of the
particles the next thing that we could
do that would be fairly straightforward
it would be to determine the bulk volume
that is the volume of the particles plus
the spaces between the particles and we
can do that by putting the parfaits into
this graduated cylinder
try and get one level
the divisions on this graduated cylinder
are in increments of 10 milliliters the
volume of the beads is 440 milliliters
so please enter that on your sheet and
now we're going to determine these
volumes of the particles I have here
some water that I put some dye in and
I'm going to put this into the graduated
cylinder and the volume here is 390
milliliters and the next step the
dramatic step is to pour the beads into
this graduated cylinder exactly as we
did for the single quartz pebble before
only we're doing it maybe 100 times over
and we can see that the water level has
risen of course and we can also note
that the spaces between the particles
are completely filled with liquid here
the pore space that is the open space
between the particles is connected and
fluids water in this case can move
freely between the particles this is an
important term called permeability it
means simply the ability of fluids to be
transmitted by rock or regolith and
clearly the spaces between these
particles are connected and fluid moves
easily between them the new volume is
640 milliliters so if you enter that on
your sheet and then you can see by
looking at your sheet that we can now
determine the volume of the particles by
subtracting the initial volume of the
water from the final that is 390 from
640 gives us 250 milliliters as the
volume of the particles now since the
bulk volume was the volume of the
particles plus the volume of the pore
space we can also now determine the
amount of open space in these particles
the original bulk volume was 440
milliliters the volume of the particles
was 250 so subtracting 250 from 440
gives us 190 milliliters which is the
volume of the open space or pore space
between the particles the rest of this
is really some simple calculations we
can determine the porosity that's number
9 on your sheet which is the percentage
percentage of open space and we do that
by dividing 190 the volume of the pore
space over the total volume the bulk
volume of 440 and we get 43% so 43% of
volume of these particles is open space
and conversely the particles take up 57%
of the space we can also now determine
the density remember density is the
weight divided by the volume so we could
do the bulk density which would be the
weight which is we determined right at
the beginning three hundred and sixty
six point seven grams divide that by the
bulk volume of four hundred and forty
milliliters and we find out that the
bulk density is point eight three grams
per milliliter or grams per cubic
centimeter that's not particularly
useful but much more useful is the
density of the particles themselves if
we know the density of the particles
themselves and may give us some
information that would be very useful in
determining what the particles are made
of in this case we divide three hundred
and sixty six point seven which is the
weight of the particles by the volume of
the particles 250 milliliters and we
find out that the density of these
styrene beads is one point four seven
grams per cubic centimeter which makes
sense the density of water is one gram
per cubic centimeter and of course these
beads have sunk to the bottom if they
were less dense than water they float
and we wouldn't be able to do the
experiment okay so we have now shown you
how to measure porosity the percentage
of open space in a collection of
particles in this case the percentage of
open space in the pile of plastic beads
is about 43 percent we weighed the
particles we determine the bulk volume
of the particles and pore space we
determine the volume of the particles
the density of the particles and so
forth all these measurements are very
important for studying groundwater and
the flow of fluids through
to regolith on the surface of the earth
we could have done the same experiment
with this with this sand and determined
its porosity and also the density of the
particles permeability to remind you
again is the ability of fluids to flow
through rock or regolith in order for
that to happen of course there has to be
porosity but the porosity must also be
connected so that the liquid can move
from one place to another a good example
of a material that has very high
porosity but doesn't allow fluids to
move is styrofoam you take a Styrofoam
cup if you look at the walls of the
Styrofoam cup you'll see that it's made
of very tiny molds foam made from
styrene and those bubbles are not
connected they're all individually
wrapped in plastic and of course we know
the Styrofoam cup does not allow liquids
to pass through it there are some rocks
such as pumice that has similar
properties very very light and airy lots
of open space but the air space is not
connected at all so permeability is the
ability of fluids to move within sand
let's say or even in through rock where
you have fractures and this number of
porosity we'll see later on is a very
important piece of information that we
need in order to use Darcy's law which
allows us to calculate the rate at which
water flows in the subsurface until next
time this is Peter Bower in Pete's left
you